non pas de management
pourtant dans une école qu'il enseigne
vient pas vous parler d'art non plus et
pourtant je viens avec des grands
tableaux de quatre mètres sur trois sous
le bras je viens vous parler des motions
je viens vous parler de temps non pas du
temps qu'il fait mais du le temps qu'il
faut le temps qu'il faut pour
appréhender sa vie et effectivement la
rva être un support un support que
j'introduis en entreprise pour méditer
pour penser pour réfléchir et se donner
le temps de devenir plus humain alors je
m'appuie ce soir parmi plusieurs oeuvres
sur pourquoi pas kandinsky
alors quand je vous montre ce tableau de
kandinsky une oeuvre immense de quatre
mètres sur trois vous devez vous dire le
rapport avec l'entreprise est assez
floue c'est du chaos
c'est du désordre c'est un grand boum
big bull bas de couleurs qu'est ce que
l'artiste a bien voulu dire qu'est ce
qui fait que éventuellement sa touche
nos émotions
qu'est ce que fait kandinsky alors en
demies kandinsky c'est un légiste il a
été formé pour être avocat star
rationnelle et c'est une chance parce
qu'il nous a laissé plein décrit qu'est
ce qu'il essaye de faire passer là rien
à voir a priori avec la loi il est à
découvert la peinture il était comme qui
dirait mal orienté et il s'est retourné
vers la peinture il a été découvrir ce
qui se faisait en europe et il a
découvert les peintures de monnaie et il
a vu que les meules de monnaie quand ils
s'entraînaient les peindre un cône jaune
vert bleu c'était aussi beau à l'envers
qu'à l'endroit et il l'audace de rentrer
à l'intérieur de lui-même
et de se dire j'ai besoin de rendre
visible quelque chose d'invisible que
j'ai en moi j'ai besoin de rendre
visible cette invisible pour dire ma
vérité intérieure et cette démarche il
l'a fait personnellement et il est le
premier artiste qui est passé à
l'abstraction et avec l'abstraction
il a rompu avec tous les modèles
dominants
tous les modèles qui étaient en place
avec les académies tout ce qui se
faisait de bien alors on s'enlève de la
tête les artistes qui sont de 12
utopiste sont des gens qui comme vous et
comme moi ont envie de gagner leur vie
donc quand il fait ça c'est pour gagner
sa vie il fait ça pour gagner sa vie
pour dire sa vérité intérieure et rendre
visible l'invisible
parce qu'à l'époque de freud quand il
peint en 1913 cette composition
il considère ça comme une oeuvre achevée
et non pas comme un grand désordre
chaotique bruyant il parle d'une oeuvre
extrêmement achevée et une composition
désordonnée
ça peut sembler un oxymore comment at il
fait il a mis un an de méditation quatre
heures pour la peindre il est rentré à
l'intérieur de lui et il a réfléchi il a
senti ses émotions parce que les
émotions ont des couleurs les émotions
on déforme les émotions on en a tous
quelle est la couleur de vos émotions
est ce que vous êtes capables à un
moment donné de vous dire mes émotions
une forme et qu'est ce que cette forme a
peut-être à me dire aujourd'hui pour me
faire avancer
c'est ça la démarche de kandinsky c'est
une démarche qui nous touche parce
qu'elle est tellement humaine
et là c'est le temps de l'émergence et
le sens du jaillissement c'est le temps
de la genèse de l'oeuvre c'est le temps
de la naissance et c'est ce temps là
qu'il faut respecter qu'il faut prendre
le temps d'analyser de réfléchir et on
est en 1913 comme une oeuvre
prémonitoire peut-être de la guerre et
puis la guerre éclate et kandinsky
rentrer en russie il était en allemagne
il crée des musées ils créent des
oeuvres et
dix ans après il est appelé de nouveau
en allemagne dans une école non pas
sciences po mais une école d'art le bas
aura hausse le bain rose c'est l'école
qui créent les designers qui créait les
architectes ceux qui vont créer cet art
un peu rigide qui va donner naissance à
le corbusier et on peut même aller
jusqu'à aux meubles ikea
voyez un peu académique on va dire est
raide mais il est devenu avec cette
composition qui s'appelle composition 8
la précédente s'appelait composition 7
on est dix ans après dix ans pour la
prochaine composition peuvre achevée
parce que les autres oeuvres de
kandinsky elle s'appelait improvisation
fugue
on était dans la légèreté dans quelque
chose de l'ordre de la création légère
les compositions c'est sérieux et cette
composition elle s'appelle composition 8
et il est appelé maintenant en tant
qu'enseignant il est appelé en tant
qu'homme transmetteur on est passé du
temps de l'émergence
ce temps qu'il fallait respecter en dix
ans plus tard au temps du la passation
autant de la transmission autant de
l'enseignement et voyez que son oeuvre
est maintenant construite avec ce grand
triangle un peu rigide qui est ponctuée
par ces petits cercles comme des perles
comme des notes de musique qui viennent
s'inscrire dans la structure qui est
maintenant organiser parce que le temps
de la transmission et celui de
l'organisation
il est celui où il faut commencer à
pouvoir donner un discours construit aux
autres mais il ne peut se construire que
s'il a été construit sur quelque chose
qui a été de l'ordre du jaillissement
l'oeuvre précédente
et cette construction kandinsky elle
n'est pas raide
elle n'est pas systématique parce qu'il
dit et j'aime beaucoup ces phrases créer
un monde créé une oeuvre pardon c'est
créer un monde à quel monde géant j'ai
envie de créer j'ai envie d'appartenir
et c'est ça qu'il propose un monde léger
un monde de couleurs un monde où on
retrouve ce jaillissement mais qui est
maintenant structurée
qu'est ce que ça veux vous dire à vous
étudiants enseignants chercheurs
créateurs d'entreprise futur ou déjà
créé qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
transmettre à d'autres la capacité de
créer une oeuvre et le temps passe deux
ans plus tard avant que son oeuvre ne
soit considérée comme dégénéré et
expulsé d'allemagne par les nazis deux
ans plus tard il va créer ça et cette
oeuvre là qu'est ce que vous pouvez bien
ressentir maintenant regarder ce qui se
passe sur la partie gauche on retrouve
ces petites lignes légère de l'oeuvre
précédentes comme un soleil ou un visage
c'est le jaune c'est le rayonnement
c'est le professeur qui domine son son
auditoire j'ai envie de dire et qui sait
ce qu'il a à dire
et puis à droite il ya ce grand cercle
noir avec des serpentins comme une lune
avec nos serpentins intérieur nos ombres
nos côtés moins lumineux nos recherches
nos peurs nos émotions
celle qu'on ne peut pas nommer parce que
parler des motions en entreprise et de
temps ce sont de gros mots on ne parle
pas de ça on parle de ce qu'ont réussi à
faire
et là il nous montre ces deux polarités
mon côté solaire et mon côté lunaire
comme si comme dit la chanson
le soleil avait rendez vous avec la lune
et danser tortillon qui sont nos
tortillant interne brusquement au milieu
il mais ce qui fait le chef-d'oeuvre
ce qui fait que l'oeuvre n'est pas
divisée en deux comme quelque chose de
austère et juste systématique il mais ce
rouge
ce rouge comme disait un grand historien
d'art qui s'appelle arras on n'y voit
rien c'est un espèce de tache mais c'est
dur ou
c'est du rouge sang c'est du rouge
passion et sur ceux rouges flottent des
formes anamorphique et des damiers des
damiers des damiers du jeu et du dernier
du jeu quel jeu va s'inscrire sur ce jeu
c'est là que ça se passe au milieu
cantenot polarité se retrouvent non pas
d'arrêter personnel ou les polarités des
gens avec qui nous travaillons
celui qui est mon nom mon opposé celui
qui m'exaspère qui est mon ombre dont je
suis la lumière ou dont je suis l'ombre
et dont il est la lumière ou mais
polarise été intérieur qui me divise qui
m'arrache et comment chercher à trouver
cette unité intérieure parce que après
le jaillissement de quelque chose de
l'ordre de la première oeuvre de dire sa
nécessité intérieure dans la deuxième il
crée un monde et dans la troisième il va
essayer d'approfondir et de rechercher
l'essentiel l'essentiel de l'humanité
qui se joue dans cet entre deux dans cet
entre-deux qui peut être dramatique mais
c'est cet entre deux là qui permet de
créer aujourd'hui des entreprises ou
comme notre speaker précédent disait on
peut arriver à avoir une force
collective en jouant sur nos différences
intérieur personnel est aussi sur toutes
celles de des autres personnes avec qui
nous fonctionnons et je vous demande de
regarder cette oeuvre
elle est à beaubourg on a la chance de
l'avoir elle est en france c'est un des
grands chefs-d'oeuvre de kandinsky
elle peut peut-être vous parlez pour
vous dire comment je peux moi chercher à
devenir l'artiste de ma vie et que tous
ensemble nous pouvons essayer de créer
en s'inspirant en prenant le temps de
contacter nos émotions
en prenant le temps de prendre le temps
d'atteindre une plus grande humanité a
créé ensemble
à la manière des artistes pour devenir
les artistes de nos vies je vous
remercie